hey guys Pete here this will be my
breakdown of watzmann Season one Episode
four it was directed by a dredge Perec
was written by damon lindelof and
crystal henry and was titled if you
don't like my story write your own which
appears to be a nod to Chinua Achebe a
rabbit hole that i've yet to go down we
get another major character introduction
more angela and a few more clues about
what adrian byte is up to generally
speaking things seem to move in Episode
four rather than just asking more
questions and I like the timing of the
reveals it seems like the writers have
an awareness of how fans will react and
dissect the information so far they
appear to have a handle on when to give
us something to keep our heads in the
story without ruining the mystery well
this wasn't my favorite episode out of
the four that we've seen it was still a
very good al or a television and it
feels like things are moving along full
steam ahead
we've had some hints of lady true in the
show and learned some of her backstory
from the PD pedia in Episode four she
arrives at a home she wants to acquire
to say that she makes a dramatic
entrance would be an understatement with
the three minute hourglass and a baby in
tow she makes the family an offer they
can't refuse for their property a legacy
a biological child that they were told
they would never be able to have her
plan works and just in the nick of time
as they sign the paper something crashes
to the earth outside and we at least see
what was up with the ergency even if we
don't fully understand what is happening
we'll learn a little bit more about the
trillionaire later in the episode but
first impressions are that she's all
business she tells the couple that she
got rich making advanced Pharma and
biomedical tech I liked everything about
this sequence from islands in the stream
to her saying she would have to destroy
the baby and the characterization and
performance is on par with what we've
come to expect with this watchmen series
what crash to earth is a complete
mystery but it certainly looked like
lady true and her daughter were
expecting it to be there at her bakery
angela chops up wills wheelchair so that
she can fit it into a duffel bag and
dispose of it later she cleans up any
traces of him being there and
accidentally burns the watch over this
boy note after she reconsiders
destroying it she gets a message from
the greenwood center for cultural
heritage about another branch of wills
family tree being identified which
prompts her to suit up and head over
and break in there we find out what the
cool-looking holographic tree we saw in
the trailers actually is angela is able
to see her great-grandparents and see
the image of her grandfather will as a
child there's a really strong seen here
as Angela talks to the image and then
asked that her grandfather leave her the
[ __ ] alone at that exact moment her car
falls from the sky which we've already
seen from Lori's perspective at the end
of the last episode the two women have a
quick back-and-forth about it being
Angela's car and that it fell from the
sky before Lorie takes off complimenting
sister night-school costume angela
recovers her grandfather's pills from
the glove box and then heads home after
a talk with Topher and filling in Callen
what's going on Angela takes the pills
to lookingglass who we find out has a
backyard bunker he's developing pictures
of the last squid fall and we get the
idea that he might be obsessed with the
interdimensional nature of them a squid
truther perhaps after Angela asked him
to get his x2 identified the pills she
also asked him to hold on to the Klan
robes she found in Crawford's closet
this sets up one of my favorite lines
from the episode where LG tells her to
watch out for Laurie because she's
extremely weird it's funny because the
guy developing squid photos in his
backyard bunker said it but it also
points out how the woman who grew up
being trained from an early age to
become a costume adventurer is actually
the one that serves the purpose of
bringing the story back down to the
ground when it teeters on going
completely weird sort of throughout the
episode angela is trying to investigate
will and her connection to him while
trying to fly under Laurie's radar as
she disposes of the duffle with the
wheelchair she crosses paths with a man
in a costume that Red Scare later dubs
Lube man there's no telling who this
character is but his MO appears to be
squirting lubrication that he carries in
a holster on his waist over his costume
so that he can slide effortlessly in the
sewer drains Angela doesn't have time to
learn more after a quick run-in with
keen that acts to remind us that he's
probably shady and a short exchange with
Red Scare and pirate Jenny that
reestablishes the police's priorities
she has a conversation with Laurie who
has now taken over Crawford's office
there we learn that the FBI got a match
on an unknown set of prints found
Angela's car they belonged to William
Reeves and the big reveal here is that
he was a police officer in New York City
in the 1940s and 50s
Angela finds out that her grandfather
retired young and disappeared and we get
confirmation that he was in New York
City at the time the Minutemen were
active and was a cop just like Hollis
Mason who was the original Nite Owl does
this mean that he's hooded justice
not exactly but it does seem to put him
in the right place at the right time it
makes it seem less likely that he
wouldn't have some connection to the
beginning of costume adventuring but
we'll have to wait to learn more about
what role he actually played he could be
hooded justice a lot of people think he
is but there may be more to the story as
well Angela acts like she doesn't know
who he is and as far as what Laurie
tells her it's probable that the FBI
haven't realized that they're related
yet
PD comes in to interrupt which sets up a
trip to true industries on the ride
Laurie lays out the idea that people who
wear masks are driven by trauma they
become obsessed with justice because of
some injustice they suffer usually when
they were kids
sister Knight pushes back and asked what
trauma she suffered Laurie asked agent
PD to fill in the blanks which he does
he explains that her father the comedian
attempted to rape her mother Silk
Spectre he doesn't mention it but by the
end of the comic we find out that in
spite of this happening her parents went
on to have a consensual relationship
after the fact where Laurie was
conceived this whole chain of events
with Laurie being born from her mother
loving a man that she should have
probably hated played a role in dr.
Manhattan returning to Earth he referred
to it as a thermodynamic miracle which
is what Laurie is referring to when she
talks about Angela's car being stolen on
the night of Crawford's murder and being
returned on the night of his funeral
wherever Laurie is there's a strong
connection to the source material and
that holds true when they arrive to meet
lady true after getting a look at the
drone craft that agent Blake points out
would be the perfect thing to steal
Angela's car with the pair are invited
into truths vivarium by her daughter the
vivarium
looks like the one Adrianne bait head at
Karnak his Antarctic retreat in the
original graphic novel which also is
where he was last presumed to be before
it was announced that he went missing in
2012 everything about lady true hints
the
she might be following in Ozymandias
footsteps including the aged up
sculpture she has of him inside her own
private Vietnam when asked about it she
calls him a truly great man and says so
much of my success grew from the seed of
his inspiration but we all know there
are no real true heroes or villains and
Watchmen so the fact that she comes off
like the bad guy is all the more
confusing bottom line is that we find
out that she helped will escape thanks
to a conversation that she has in
Vietnamese with Angela and we get the
feeling that she might be the one who
imprisoned Ozymandias after their
encounter Angela goes to find out what
Cal told Lori when she dropped by to
interview him he lied for her even
though he hates to do it which we
already had a feeling about because he
couldn't lie to the kids telling them
that Jud was in heaven we also learned
that he was involved in an accident and
it might have something to do with them
meeting each other in Vietnam back at
true industries we see beyond wake up
from the nightmare she has a mysterious
IV attached to her arm that bears the
true logo and after she tells her mother
about the dream of being marched away
from her village after men came to burn
it she just goes back to bed not before
telling mr. Reeves goodnight though and
we see that will is indeed in league
with lady T she's concerned that will
left the pills behind for Angela to
discover his counter is why is she doing
the same type of thing to her daughter
and after saying it's completely
different
lady T explains that she's afraid that
the family connection will cause will to
lose his resolve he says it won't we
discover he could walk the whole time
and that there is something coming up in
three days that they're planning that
will cause Angela to hate him he
reiterates that he's all in and the
episode ends with him repeating
tick-tock tick-tock while gazing up at
the construction of her tower in the
Adrienne Bates story we learned quite a
lot without getting any real answers the
clones of mr. Phillips and Miss
Cruikshank's are trapped in crab or
lobster pots after they start to grow in
a lake
Adrienne then loads them into a growth
accelerating machine and they come out
fully formed but hey it's not completely
unbelievable because it takes some time
before they can talk bate says that he's
been there for four years which confirms
that the candles on the cakes correspond
to the past
of one year between each anniversary he
also calls it a prison and he makes his
intention to escape it known he uses the
trebuchet he built to launch the clone
corpses into the air and we watched as
they pass through the invisible barrier
that appears to surround him and
disappear I'll say the same thing I said
last week in regards of the bait part of
the story we still don't know where he
is or what exactly is going on but it
feels right and that we're learning more
each time we visit I think that's what's
impressing me most about the whole
watchman experience right now there are
a lot of questions hanging over our
heads in the story but the show is
doling out enough answers that it ends
up coming out like it's leading us
somewhere rather than trying to outsmart
us not to say that we shouldn't expect
for obvious outcomes to be subverted but
the storytelling feels tight which is
pretty exciting considering some of the
things that we've seen unfold on the
screen while we got introduced to some
new mysteries the main ones are still
intact did will actually kill Crawford
who imprisoned Ozymandias and where
exactly is he in relation to the rest of
the story is the 7th cavalry being led
by someone to serve a larger purpose
after episode 4 all these questions feel
like they could be connected at the same
time what are the chances that lady Tru
is behind all of it and the series ends
with her being found out and dealt with
we can expect some twists and turns but
right now I don't think we should expect
that we won't get answers angela is a
character who's earned our trust in the
sense that her motivations are fairly
clear her boss and good friend got
killed her grandfather that she just
learned about says he did it and she's
trying to make sense of what's happening
she's just following through like most
of us would if we were presented with
the same situations we have to like that
about her but we've also watched her
torture a guy to get answers which means
that we know she's flawed she's a real
character she's not someone that is a
hero in that traditional sense Lady
trues introduction makes her look like
she's the opposite of Angela and in the
same way she's probably not a pure
villain there's a lot going on we got
introduced to but we don't have a lot of
answers if they can keep the same
balance going that's a pretty satisfying
place to be we need to know a lot more
about will they've given us a time frame
of three days until something's going to
happen it seemed like they were
in three days that the project would be
complete the Millennium clock whatever
that does other than just tell time so
we won't have to wait for a really long
time to figure out what's going on with
him Ozymandias is the same kind of
situation we know he disappeared in 2012
we've seen four years pass in his story
we can reasonably expect that he's going
to collide with the main story in the
present timeline how that's gonna go
down is anybody's guess but certainly
he's flinging things out of his
enclosure they're going somewhere it's
all a test so that he can do the same
thing for himself I mean that seems like
the best guess Loree kind of took a back
seat here again as Angela took over the
main driving of the episode and her
influence on the story like I said heals
more like a lasso to pull things back in
we know a lot about her backstory from
the original comic series the PDP do was
all about her this week so we learned
some more about her and her pile is an
interview that's redacted so we don't
get a crystal-clear picture but we see
how she came to be in a position where
she had to work for them at the very
least things are moving in the right
direction
it feels pretty darn tight at this point
I haven't lost one bit of interest the
mysteries just get deeper but at the
same time it feels like answers will be
delivered so let me know in the comments
what you thought about episode 4 I'll
have your positions on what the answers
to the mysteries might be have changed
where do you think things are headed how
do you think it will all play out what
are your favorite series this week I
should have some bonus videos to follow
up on this I will definitely do a
trailer breakdown next as soon as I
finish my mr. robot video so be on the
lookout for that and please subscribe
please like this video if you enjoyed it
and let me know in the comments what
you'd like to see as far as bonus
material thanks for watching I'll talk
to you soon